y
[Música]
en argentina avanzan las elecciones
primarias abiertas simultáneas y
obligatorias conocidas como paso para
elegir a los candidatos a las elecciones
generales del 14 de noviembre la jornada
ha transcurrido con total normalidad y
será una prueba de popularidad y
aceptación de la gestión del presidente
alberto fernández tenemos reportes de
buenos aires
marie le pen la del líder de la extrema
derecha en francia se dio el liderazgo
de su partido para oficializar su
aspiración a la presidencia del país con
el control migratorio como bandera de
campaña también la alcaldesa de parís
anne hidalgo anunció que será candidata
también a las presidenciales del 2022 se
espera que el presidente manuel macro no
haga lo mismo
irán permitirá que inspectores de la onu
reactiva en cámaras de vigilancia en las
plantas nucleares de la república
islámica esto después de que el
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica acusar a teherán por su poca
colaboración en el proceso de
normalización de las relaciones entre
ese organismo y la república islámica
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar en argentina
en donde avanza a esta hora la jornada
de votación de las primarias abiertas
simultáneas y obligatorias conocidas
como paso en las que serán elegidos los
candidatos de las elecciones generales
del 14 de noviembre para renovar una
parte del senado y de la cámara de
diputados las primarias servirán de
sondeo de la fortaleza de aceptación que
tiene el gobierno del presidente alberto
fernández quien ha hecho frente a la
crisis de la pandemia del cob y 19 a una
profunda crisis económica y a un
drástico aumento de la pobreza en todo
el país lo que podría llevar también a
una pérdida de la mayoría en el congreso
natalio cosoi desde buenos aires nos da
más detalles en su reporte
ya han pasado varias horas desde el
inicio de estas elecciones primarias
para decidir las listas que competirán
en las legislativas del 14 de noviembre
cuando se renovarán en argentina la
mitad más o menos de la cámara de
diputados y aproximadamente un tercio
del senado la votación comenzó a las 8
de la mañana en centros de votación como
el que se encuentra a mis espaldas en
muchos casos son escuelas son unos
17.500 un poco más de centros de
votación 20 por ciento más que en otras
ocasiones previendo la situación de
pandemia para que se distribuyan más los
votantes en diferentes centros en el
inicio hubo algunos reportes de demoras
en los centros de votación fuera de eso
es una elección normal que se está
desarrollando en forma tranquila
concluirá la votación aproximadamente a
las 18 horas de argentina y se esperan
los primeros resultados para las 23
horas no muy lejos de allí en brásil
movimientos de centro y derecha
convocaron a protestas en diferentes
ciudades de ese país los manifestantes
exigen el inicio con miras a la
destitución del presidente de ayer
bolsonaro por considerarlo como una
amenaza para la democracia del país
después de haber atacado verbalmente a
varias instituciones del estado
estamos protestando contra un presidente
que traicionó todo el discurso que hizo
durante la campaña
hoy él va contra todo lo que dijo que
haría él es un corrupto formó una
asociación criminal dentro de su propia
familia
él roba el dinero de todo el país
roba cunas negó la ciencia
hoy hubo una división entre los partidos
de izquierda y esto acabó contaminando
el acto creo que hoy es un día para
decir fuera bolsonaro independientemente
de ser de izquierda de derecha o de
centro hoy no es un día partidario es un
día para la humanidad yo estoy aquí para
la humanidad dejamos américa latina' nos
vamos hasta europa faltan ya siete meses
para las elecciones presidenciales en
francia y este domingo dos mujeres
anunciaron su intención de competir al
principal cargo ese país la socialista y
también alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo
y la ultraderechista marine le pen se
espera también que el actual presidente
manuel marco aspire a su reelección y
haga el anuncio en las próximas horas el
informes de manuel acá comienza la
campaña presidencial en francia con el
anuncio de las candidaturas
la líder de la extrema derecha marie le
pen espera que la tercera sea la vencida
lópez hizo de la lucha contra la
migración su bandera el yoga para don
wow
no habrá lugar en francia donde no se
aplique la ley
nos deja amigos míos erradicaremos
barrios peligrosos pandillas mafias y
todos aquellos islamistas o no que
quieran imponernos reglas y una forma de
vida que no es nuestro es de este mundo
en francia los franceses tienen derecho
a vivir como los franceses y jose
más temprano la alcaldesa de parís anne
hidalgo hizo lo propio la primera mujer
en ocupar ese cargo puso precisamente
como prioridad los derechos de las
mujeres dependerá de las mujeres
decidirlo dependerá de los franceses
decidirlo serán ellos quienes transmitan
la idea de que las mujeres en puestos de
responsabilidad marcan de una diferencia
positiva en la vida de las mujeres y los
hombres hija de una pareja de españoles
que huyeron de la dictadura franquista
francia representa al partido socialista
según reuters en las últimas encuestas
el presidente manuel marco cuenta con el
24 por ciento de la intención de voto
lepén con el 20 hidalgo con un 8% la
ahora candidata para las elecciones del
2022 buscará unir la fragmentada
izquierda francesa cambiamos de tema
irán anunció que permitirá que los
inspectores de la onu operen cámaras de
vigilancia en las plantas nucleares
iraníes esto luego de que el director
general del organismo internacional de
energía atómica la agencia perteneciente
a la onu se reunió este domingo
con el nuevo jefe de la organización de
energía atómica de ese país asiático la
visita se produjo luego de que la
agencia nuclear de la onu emitiera un
informe acusando a la república islámica
de su falta de cooperación el informes
de andré amaya
han llegado a un acuerdo con la agencia
nuclear de la onu para darle más
tranquilidad al mundo sobre sus alcances
permitiendo que inspectores del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica reactiva en cámaras de
vigilancia ubicadas en sus centrales
nucleares
la continuidad de las operaciones del
equipo de la agencia es indispensable
para nosotros para brindar las garantías
necesarias y la información al organismo
y al mundo de que todo está en orden y
que vamos a poder ayudar
además para ayudar a irán en sus futuras
negociaciones en el contexto del plan de
acción integral conjunto el acuerdo
llega con el fin de evitar un
enfrentamiento diplomático sin embargo
la decisión no convence del todo a la
agencia de la onu teherán no dijo si
entregara a copias de las grabaciones
con las que amenazó previamente diciendo
que las destruiría
acordamos que para el cambio de las
tarjetas de memoria de las cámaras de
vigilancia el equipo técnico relacionado
vendrá a irán después del acuerdo para
que puedan hacer las medidas técnicas
necesarias para las cámaras y las
tarjetas de memoria pero según el
acuerdo de salvaguardia las tarjetas
antiguas serán selladas y guardadas en
irán
en julio de 2015 irán y seis potencias
mundiales llegaron a un histórico
acuerdo que limitaba el programa nuclear
iraní a cambio del levantamiento de
sanciones económicas en 2018 eeuu bajo
la presidencia de donald trump se retiró
de dicho acuerdo y le impuso los
castigos a iran la república islámica
respondió incumpliendo muchas de las
restricciones del acuerdo enriqueciendo
uranio a una pureza más alta y
acercándose cada vez más al nivel
adecuado para fabricar armas nucleares
se espera que la próxima semana se
reúnan los representantes de la agencia
nuclear de la onu para decidir si
presionar más a irán a través de una
resolución que no obstante pondría en
peligro la reanudación de las
negociaciones en viena
el ejército de siria consiguió ingresar
a la ciudad de daráa en el sur del país
y que por más de una década ha estado
controlada por los grupos rebeldes el
acceso de las tropas leales al
presidente bashar al-assad se da en
medio de una frágil tregua con los
rebeldes que fue negociada por rusia
dará fue el lugar donde surgió el
levantamiento contra el gobierno del
presidente al asad en el año 2011 la
ciudad ha sido prácticamente destruida
por los enfrentamientos y sus actuales
residentes se enfrentan escasez de
alimentos medicinas y no tienen acceso a
servicios esenciales
antes de despedir este informativo demos
un vistazo a lo que tenemos publicado en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
tenemos destacado allí las elecciones
paso en argentina tenemos allí un minuto
a minuto de cómo han transcurrido esta
jornada electoral de domingo allí en
argentina para elegir a los candidatos
de las elecciones de noviembre
es todo por el momento siga con nuestra
programación buenas tardes
[Música]